a fifth grader is showing off their  history knowledge in a very unique way  students at Ronaldo Martinez Elementary  hosted their living wax museum yesterday  so each one researched an historical  American figure and then they dressed up  as that history character checking check  it out for yourself it's really was  quite impressive hello my name is jungle  I lived during the 1900s when there's  segregation in Winter it  about me I I was I was the first man to  eat in space  first human being in space and he still  looks so young well visitors were  invited to walk through and see the  different displays as well as student  reenactments really really impressive  and the kids learned so much by living  the history  the best way to do it get yourself  immersed